en annonçant l'évacuation mais on ne la
faisons pas
et je n'ai pas du tout envie de donner
des chiffres qui ne sont ni ne se sont
pas réalisées parce qu'il y avait huit
bus
qui sont arrivés finalement mais nous
nous attendions beaucoup plus
en plus de cela
ils devaient nous indiquer le trajet
précis
pour qu'on puisse charger au fur et à
mesure ces bus
donc avec plus de personnes mais il
n'avait pas ses intentions là
donc nous pouvons parler de la rive
gauche de notre ville qui est coupé de
l'autre partie de la ville et c'était
très difficile d'évacuer les gens là bas
mais les gens sont venus
sur ce point qui était indiqué comment
est en pointe de vos créations mais le
combat avait commencé et il y avait des
tirs il y avait des chars qui étaient
venus
et les personnes apeurées ont pris la
décision
personnelle
de partir de ne pas partir et beaucoup
d'entre eux ont malheureusement pris la
décision de rester dans la ville parce
que ils sont considérés qu'il était
dangereux pour pour leur vie de partir
il n'y a que quatre bus qu'ils sont
partis et aujourd'hui et sont fait un
nom ils ont fait un long chemin ils se
sont arrêtés pour la nuit à berthier en
ce qu
ils se sont arrêtés sur abassi l'ifca
tous ces personnes là sont en direction
de zaporijia actuellement
nous sommes
très contents combien de personnes pas
vous vous réussir et vécu depuis tout ce
temps a dans ces conditions compliquées
et je souligne encore une fois tout est
sous le contrôle de nos
soit disant libérateur mais en réalité
des occupants qui ont détruit notre
ville et qui
terrorise les cent mille habitants
nous avons un
chat potté cette mission d'évacuation à
grâce à un autre et ronald richoux cas à
la ministre du territoire équipé avec un
volet dit mercelis qui est il y à plus
de cent mille personnes qui ont réussi à
quitter
donc c'est une
proportion très petit
c'est une c'est un chiffre qui est très
petit par rapport au nombre d'habitants
donc les 100000 qui sont restés mais
quelques centaines qui ont été évacués
nous espérons que le couloir humanitaire
pourra être mise en place est ce qu'il
est ce que ça marche est ce que vous
avez ces informations je souligne encore
une fois depuis les premiers jours du
mars
au nom donner cette possibilité
d'indiquer des points
on pourrait commencer effectué
l'évacuation donc les champs se
rassembler dans sûr c'est dans ces
endroits mais
nos bus étaient détruits par des tirs
malheureusement tous les bus étaient
détruits et donc l'évacuation qui était
prévu à marioupol a été n'a pas pu avoir
lieu
se voit depuis deux jours
nous annonçons que il y aura une
évacuation
donc nous avons
annoncé ce point d'évacuation il ya plus
de 200 habitants qui attendent cette
évacuation
ils ne savent pas si elle aura lieu ou
pas
donc on leur a dit qu'il fera on pourra
évacuer que à des enfants et des femmes
après on leur dit
que ce sera que des femmes donc les
champs
attendent
attendent un bus sur le poids que nous
avons défini le plan d'évacuation mais à
15 heures et il est toujours pas là nous
espérons que l'armée
de l'occupant pourra permettre cette
évacuation
est que le bus prendra le trajet que
nous avons définie et qui nous
permettront de prendre en chemin
d'autres
passagers en passer par béria est allé
jusqu'à sa porsche a mais
malheureusement il n'y a pas de bus pour
le moment nous avons invité nous avons
demandé votre deux bus qui devait venir
à 14 heures mais là il est 15h 05 il n'y
a rien les personnes attendent mais
malheureusement il n'y a rien qui se
passe donc nous attendons du
monsieur maxime nous
constatons comme on dit chez nietzsche
ou
iliad et
il y avait des tortures des personnes
qui ont lieu
il y à des files d'attentes qui
rassemble de milliers de personnes est
ce que l'occupant essayent d'empêcher
les gens de bien partir pourquoi ils
font ça cette procédure
donc cette procédure c'est de retenir
l'évacuation vers l'ukraine
c'est une procédure plus compliqué de
filtration
il s'est lié aux services
les personnes peuvent être kidnappé et
retenu pendant à un mois deux mois
nous avons une position très claire
lorsque nous parlons des tortures il y a
beaucoup d'habitants de notre ville qui
ont subi des tortures qui ont subi ces
atrocités
il n'y a pas que les hommes
si
sensible de ces tortures mais aussi des
femmes et des personnes qui ont passé
par cette filtration ont témoigné ont pu
témoigner et c'est juste une horreur il
témoigne de l'horreur
il proposait cette opération de
libération
mais on nous voyons que c'est un
génocide qui se passe c'est un ghetto
qu'on met en place il y a quatre centres
qui sont
qui existe est par exemple mon voisin
qui étaient inscrits à cette opération
de filtration il a obtenu donc un ticket
un numéro 6 en vain donc on nous voyons
le nombre de personnes qui font la queue
donc ces personnes là passent par ce
point de filtration
et peut-être qu'il aura cette super
cette personne a aura cette possibilité
de partir vers nos territoires donc ça
c'est des tortures c'est des méthodes
fascistes que l'allemagne fasciste avait
utilisé maintenant c'est la russie
fasciste qu'ils utilisent
est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer les
informations que nous avons vu dans les
médias
qui dit qu'il y à des enterrements
de masse de sous la ville de man bush
malheureusement je confirme ces
informations nous avons constaté que la
ville
ça fait déjà deux semaines qu'elle est
fermée et que personne ne peut rentrer
aujourd'hui il utilise
la méthode à de
nettoyage
je rappelle
que d'après nos estimations
optimistes si je peux le dire il ya plus
de vingt mille civils donc les enfants
les personnes âgées
sont morts sous le feu de l'occupant il
y a aussi les témoignages
de
nos représentants municipaux
nous voyons une quantité énorme de corps
de ses habitants de marie paule qui sont
morts et des personnes qui disparaissent
aussi donc nous avons quelques
informations mais cette information est
fermée et elle est dangereuse
donc c'est dangereux pour eux deux de
nos communiqués sans formation afin
qu'on puisse les communiqués puisqu'il
s'agit des crimes de guerre ils essayent
de cacher ses crimes de guerre c'est
pour ça qu'ils utilisent trois outils
pour le cacher donc c'est des fosses
communes
nous voyons que autour de mon bouche et
il y à une
route périphérique
une rue d'une route qui entoure cette
ville
est donc derrière il ya une rivière
cimetière et un côté un champ donc dans
ce chan ils creusent des fosses de
quatre mètres de long et il transporte
les corps par des camions des habitants
des civils de marioupol pour enterrer
dans ces fosses